le sourire est une histoire qui est
une
action intensément psychologique mais qui est aussi imprégnée de ce
sentiment de malaise rampant je vois
quelque chose que personne d'autre ne peut voir ce qui
se passe quand vous le voyez ça
me sourit mais pas un sourire amical c'est le
pire sourire que j'ai  jamais vu je voulais
créer un film qui ressemble à un
cauchemar qui s'intensifie
avant de mourir
elle souriait
elle est confrontée à quelque chose
d'horrible
le mal dans le film utilise un sourire comme
masque pour cacher ses véritables intentions
elle commence à croire que quelque chose
le mal est peut-être entré dans sa vie
quelque chose me menace
elle perd le contact
gelé vous entendez-vous d'une manière très
réelle
cette histoire est juste le genre de chose
où vous vous demandez si cela pourrait
arriver dans la vraie vie et c'est pourquoi ça
vous aspire  pense vraiment que tu devrais
parler à quelqu'un je ne suis pas fou de faire face
à quelque chose auquel tu ne peux pas échapper et de ne pas
savoir d'où ça vient
c'est effrayant
je ne sais pas ce que c'est
mais je vois je  t partout comment
cela vous fait-il sentir
ce que vous êtes
rien ne peut vous préparer à ce qui va
se passer
les peurs
et la façon dont la caméra a raconté l'histoire
c'est quelque chose que nous n'avons vraiment jamais
vu auparavant
et c'est tellement effrayant
ce n'est pas réel
[Musique  ]
vous